all around me are scary
faces hell and
tedes I hate
fredy's dark and scary in my lonely
office going
nowhere go going
nowhere my fear is feeling up there
EOS no
expression no
expression hide my head inside this mask
so
Hollow when
tomorrow when
tomorrow and I find it kind of scary I
find it kind of strange the Bears is
still roaming around this place I'm
pretty scared I have no one to turn to I
find one on the run when tedes running
circles it's a very
very strange
World Strange
World slowly waiting for the day to stop
love the
sunrise love the
sunrise but I won't run away like every
man would come on
tedes come on
Ted back to work and I was very
nervous Please don't hug me please don't
hurt
me hello Teddy tell me what you
demon look right past me look right past
me
hi guys I hope you enjoyed this song
written and put together by TCS it was
so much fun to sing and he did an
amazing job with the video be sure to
check out his channel for more gaming
parodies the links are in the
description I'd appreciate a like if you
enjoyed the video and if we get 500
likes then a longer version of this song
will be put onto iTunes for you all
minus the desk cream don't worry have a
lovely day or evening
bye